[Music]
have you ever had a night like this ever
in your entire life
[Music]
go say hello buy him a drink
hi i'm sheila hi hi i'm uh i'm gary can
i get you hold on
thank you
cheers mate
that was kind of weird
oh not really
i have got to come clean with you
i'm from the future
wait i'm i'm sorry i'm a little confused
so how much do you use the tanning
machine oh no it's not a tan machine
it's a time machine
try it it's fun
i've spent the entire week with you this
night seven times in a row
[Music]
wait what'd you do with the other you
from the past
do you think i'm crazy
but it's really cute okay
you ever had a night like this ever in
your entire life
i just wanted to change a couple things
to make you more perfect this never
happened with old gary
if you erase the pain you erase the
person what exactly did you change about
me i have this ability to take your pain
away it's not yours to take away sheila
it came from a good play scary yeah so
did gender reveal parties
started as an accident
and i fell in love with you
and this time
i am gonna make it work
a real sophie's choice kind of decision
now isn't it i love it when you make
that joke
what what
[Music]
you didn't want to go somewhere more
meaningful like i don't know like to
kill hitler well i did take out smithson
who exactly
you